[Music]
oh
i blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
you sure have bad luck sam greenfield
take that universe
oh until
i found an actual lucky penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
and what did i do
i flushed it down the toilet
you flushed my penny down the toilet
you just
talked
wait i just need another penny
[Music]
who was with the obnoxiously long
password
humans cannot be here where's here
the land of luck i'll leave as soon as
you give me another lucky penny you best
start blending in hello
mighty leprechaun fry line well done
nature
this is where good luck is born
a dragon
she's the only creature that can sniff
out bad luck there's bad luck here too
good looking top bad luck on the bottom
the tiniest amount of bad luck can shut
down our entire operation
just how unlucky are you
oh no
super duper unlucky you cause a disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed
i do you and everyone else to a life of
bad luck we need to fix this
what are you doing here
good luck to us both
what about jeff un style you asked i
don't go down i have no words
[Music]
you